千万不要太资率啊
资率这个就是个假象
就是你越是屁民民主帝资率的人
越你用失败的可能就就越大
就让我们变得越来越好的方法
反而是能够人数我们自己暂时没什么变化
或者进步比较小
就我们从小的如果被关除了一种什么的
要成功 懂一努力加坚持
因为我们是怎么办 努力 坚持 加油
对吧
给你加个一周两周三周一个月
你一定会放弃的
为什么
因为那个意志历史有限的你用完了就用完了
让我们获得成长的方法
不是推个句实话三上推一
而是找到一种顺流而下的方法
就为什么呢
就是我们这个大脑一旦遇到压力会怎么办
它就会先入自责
就会先入教律
就会先入那样
就你红真都不输出
然后这个大脑就会进入一种危险模式
所以说不信不信这个状态太跑了
我们推出安全的状态
回到我以前的席文
就你是坚持不下来的
但是如果你能够放松你能不天啊
这个事情反而能够持久了
就像那个杀子一样啊
给了你会发现
我们手里反应说那个杀子全都没了
你要稍微放弄一下呢
这个手上反而会有很多杀子
就我们要留那种红苏斯里
就接受一个生物能够换漫的漫漫的成长
我给大家说的最简单的例子吧
就是如果你走个对抗走个对抗总是有压力
总是自责总是就你漫漫就坚持不下去了
但是如果你的做的公主能够呢
如果你很舒服
你很放松
其实你不觉得这个有什么
他就自然然就会变成就习惯变成一种角色
所以各位给你每一个自车的方法
就是你做完一件事以后你是累的金皮皮皮
已经特别特别累
还是做完了一会很方松
基本上就觉得这个事
你能不能做完
那么具体怎么做呢
给大家听小建议吧
就如果一个事很重要
你就像用了刚才那个方法去自错
怎么能够让他坚持下来
有些时候你不是说招揭马上做完
而是给自己一个更低版本的
能够让他执行起来
能够让他运作起来
然后一点一点就加码
比如说我一开始的时候的话
我不一定就是我一跳
我都一倍数
我一天度三月就一样
我一天是读十分钟行的一样
我不一定有一天就写一篇文章
我能不能写一段话
甚至一句话
我不一定天对我拍了我视频
对吧
那条视频一定要拍得很好
流量特别好
点赞特别多
我能忙了有些时候只是我有一个想法
我把它表达出来表现出来
就可以了
就当你感到纠绿的时候
感到内耗的时候
这个时候要放放下来
人一曲自己
暂时没有情供
或者只是庆布那么一点点
给大家几个小临意思吧
就好像说你习个听说
这时候有个上述
你努力当努力当努力当
你实际求人之力
那他也登上去的
你也请你直接进去
但这个时候的话
你反而下车来你推的这种车上山
你换卖一点
这时候人一曲自己换卖一点
人一曲自己没有情供
人一曲自己进步的卖一点
反而会为来的持久提供更多的空间
所以会好好想一想
什么事是你一定要做的
一定要做成的
那么自后一想
做完这个事以后
就是今天的经历的不行
还是做过放松的
如果经历的已经被的不行
那么好好想一想
这个事情
有没有一个更轻松的版本
给自己是进一个十分钟的版本
然后就执行
想好好想一想
想好了以后
再评论区
告诉我